logros vergonzosos que no quieres
desbloquear parte dos qué creías que ya
no tenía más logros para humillarte en
el no tan genial Príncipe de Persia las
Arenas olvidadas si te madrea más de lo
habitual y decides bajar la dificultad
en el menú de pausa el juego muy
sutilmente se burlara de ti de tu
pequeño secreto en auras rad además de
agarrarte a puñetazos con cualquier
criatura viviente también puedes relajar
tus inmensos brazos en aguas termales
Pero si te enfocas demasiado en la
belleza de la chica que te aca el juego
tomará nota de tus cochinos ojos y te
dará un logro para que todos sepan que
eres un puerco si te quedas quieto en un
solo lugar durante más de 3 minutos en
Halo 4 el juego identificará que estás
campeando como toda una rata y mediante
un logro te pedirá que te muevas y hagas
algo y en el juego de Lara Craft y el
templo de Osiris si estás jugando en el
online y eres el jugador que más veces
murió Ni creas que el juego te lo va a
dejar pasar pues te hará un logro que
dice Bueno al menos Eres el mejor en y